the girag and experience cuz he can
didn't does he elaborate any further
than that I don't I don't think so I
think he just leaves it that but still
man sean connery gets away with that
because he's handsome he's got that cool
accent but imagine somebody out saying
that Jude Law yeah it's just bad I mean
ultimately Sean Connery is just hitting
women
he's from an old school era so it's kind
of funny to hear ya that's why because
of like Jude Law don't know why I'm
saying Jude Law again but he has a
proper accent he's a handsome guy if he
wound up saying that an interview it
would ruin his career yeah absolutely
ruin his career
like who's a famous movie star today
who's like a good example like Ryan
Reynolds I guess a handsome guy I'm not
sure that is Ryan Seacrest imagine if
Ryan Seacrest said that he would know
he's gay she would know look I know what
you're doing mm probably doesn't have
time for sex okay this guy that's Ryan
Reynolds this handsome bastard if he
said that if Ryan Reynolds said that
sometimes you need to smack a woman holy
shit with the backlash be extraordinary
salon.com would dedicate months and
months of front page articles yeah but
what about all the sites defending him
none none none none to be a few of those
buggin men's rights Sean Connery fan
clubs fear those embarrassing men's
rights sites where they write things
like oh come on you know went too far
you fucks you ruined the whole argument
the whole argument is divorced laws the
whole argument the whole argument is how
many guys get fucked over finance it's
so weird salon.com started attacking
patton oswalt
you know it's not salon.com okay it's a
writer a writer decided that they were
going to pick a hot-button topic that
didn't necessarily jive or make sense
but they felt like because patton oswalt
was making fun of someone else's racism
by showing like this it's actually very
similar to what colbert is get in
trouble for right except Patton Oswalt
is a fucking like obvious comedian and
in known as a pretty sensitive aware
I like the idea that he would say
something racist just for the joke like
he was they knew what he was doing and
they decided to go for it anyway and
that's when he attacked them litter they
should have he should have they're gross
like there's something about their their
articles too if you go to salon.com one
of the things is almost every article
starts with a question you know is you
know is this the time to reconsider the
the argument of who's funny or men or
women question mark is this you know
this is is this what's wrong with the
right question mark you know like this
it's it's weird they're they're like
opinion pieces that represent this
article it just is like it's it's
amazingly this guess guess what chicken
butt does anti-vegan shaming pitch in a
preschool is that their salon article
yeah hold on mr. show patriarchal hedge
monkey in sketch show titles Tesla the
man from Nantucket anti-transgender
subtext and classic to the homeless
salon articles you dummies you fucked
with the wrong guy yeah you did he lit
him up she's right man I mean I get
angry sometimes like the other day they
were comparing Tina Fey to to louis c.k
and is the age-old argument who's
funnier men are women
fuck you fuck you here's what's funnier
funny people it's not men or women like
stop Amy Schumer hilarious Louis CK's
Larry's and Tina Fey by the way isn't
even a stand-up okay she's an actress
she's funny sure she's funny on shows
she's funny and I'm in movies but she's
not louis c.k Lucy get writes his own
shit performed his own shit it's all his
opinions on the world to say that that
there's some sort of a debate who's
funnier him is completely distorting
what the artform is in the first place
it's completely distorting it like
you're just looking for a fuckin
salacious article title that's all
you're doing I used to think I thought I
thought they were like it seems like
they were much more respected and now
they've gone down this spiral where ever
just rolling their eyes at they'll run
out of shit to talk about all right well
you know it's just ridiculous it gets to
a certain it gets a certain time when
you're covering these same stories over
and over and over and over and over and
over this cancel Colbert cancel Colbert
one fucking joke is merited like seven
or eight headlines for four articles
from them all right like in the debate
why he needs to make it right make it
right jesus fucking christ
what are you talking about make a joke
right me what was his joke I mean it was
so fun first of all he's a character
he's a right-wing ridiculous character
that says dumb shit yeah tongue-in-cheek
every fucking step of the way who is it
offensive to which Asian people I'll
pull it up right now so we could see
what the fucking Colbert controversy
I'll pull it up but people are asking
hash tagging hash tagging cancel Colbert
because of a fucking joke okay here's
the here's and he's apparently responded
to it but let's find out what how many
back how many can respond to that oh I
don't know but they're all gross I don't
know how many B's wondering how big if
it's an actual big you know no it's
pretty different is it you can scan
through it and it's not just cancel
Colbert there's like it's just like that
it's like a place where all the outraged
people have gone to express their
outrage just they're pissed about
anything and they'll just hashtag here's
what they said okay it all began
Thursday evening when the Colbert
reports Twitter account by the way which
wasn't even him wasn't even him that
wrote that was someone that handles the
Colbert account it's not it's not
Stephen Colbert quoted a joke from a
segment on Wednesdays episode so they
quoted a joke from a segment so they
took it out of context and that's where
the outrage came quoted a joke from a
segment that aired that mocked
Washington Redskins owner Dan Schneider
for setting up a charity to aid Native
Americans in lieu of changing the team's
name the original bit Colbert said he
was inspired by Snyder to start his own
charity called the ching chong ding dong
foundation for sensitivity to Orientals
or whatever
that's in response to a guy who runs a
team called the Washington Redskins
which is an anti Native American slur
making a charity for it for Native
Americans without changing the name like
there's a whole context to that joke
I mean he's not saying that there should
be a ching chong ding dong foundation
he's mocking the racism of a guy whose
team is called a racist name donating
without changing the name I mean it's so
obvious but salon has had like seven
fucking articles about it some
supportive but some that say he needs to
make it right maybe you just cannot put
that string of words together in any
contest song whatever he said I think
that's exactly what they're saying you
can't say change can't say that that's
the n-word it's hilarious I mean to try
to censor contact content that much that
you're taking things completely out of
context completely out of the the
meaning button context is the reason why
language exists in the first place it's
everything to be able to expand past
really simple things like eat fuck shit
you need context to have a goddamn
language and communicate each other we
have to recognize subtleties yes and
when you pretend they don't exist that's
when you get assholes sanctimonious fuck
heads who get crazy about jokes that
shouldn't get people dedicating days and
days of their life to something that
fucking bet there's Tracy Morgan says
about stabbing his gay son they're crazy
everything is taken completely out of
context and everything is something that
warrants cancellation you be shamed you
need to be removed this is over
sensitive fucking morons it's weird how
what you're expressing right now is
you're offended mm-hmm they offend you
that's what's interesting is it's like
they that what they are doing is so much
more offensive than the thing they are
offended by yes the way they're
expressing themselves is so vile and
disgusting that it makes whatever Tracy
Morgan said or Patton Oswalt said or
Colbert's
just seem like seems so tiny compared to
what they are which is they're like
embryonic fascists if you gave them
power and they grew out of control if
that whoever is like running the show at
salon met whoever's running the cancel
Colbert and somehow they took power
imagine what kind of world would be
living oh god if you they could decide
what gets on these comedy shows satire
shows what you can and can't get away
with how many transgenders need to be
represented how many fucking gay people
need to be represented how many fucking
straight white males need to be made fun
of along with straight white females I
mean is it gonna be a chart where
everything's graphed and made sure it's
completely even across the board that's
not life man maybe they'll find
something new to be pissed off about
because that's really what they love is
being pissed off about stuff
oh they drew they'd realize that they
lost their love which is the problem
it's it's when you say they it's writers
it's writers that they're attracting
it's not necessarily logical people it's
not necessarily like representative of
the organization itself they're
individual writers who produce something
and then somebody greenlight set but at
a certain point in time you're doing
more harm than good because you're so
easy to mock order you're like super
left-wing when you get that far out on a
fucking limb and you want to cancel Coco
Barrera Colbert about a really obvious
joke like that you're fucking up
everything because you're making
yourself look unbelievably silly right
like I know you feel right and I know
that you have this righteous indignation
behind what you're doing and you feel
like the that people need to know you
need to realize the harm that your words
say you need to realize that there's
humor okay and humor people get hurt Oh
hiding about you're a bigot hiding
behind the mask of a comedian people get
hurt people get hurt from jokes and
guess what if you get hurt from jokes
you're supposed to get hurt from those
jokes if you can't make fun of something
about yourself that means you haven't
acknowledged that something about
yourself that may or may not be
hilarious
and there's a big difference between
someone saying something unbelievably
cruel and evil and someone saying
something were there poking at you and
laughing and obviously he was doing that
obviously he was poking at the
Washington Redskins guy and laugh
and to deny that it's just it fuck's up
the whole argument if it clouds the
water with shitheads yeah it's strange
to see salon.com in some way like
converging with nancy grace's in some
way right yeah like they're meeting
somehow Solana's like put itself in this
tear whoever the writers arse put
themselves in that awful position where
it's like oh shit I'm Nancy Grace and I
her were like singing the same song and
it's not all that there's a lot of great
articles on there I still go there
because they have a lot of great
articles it's just sometimes they just
go out of line it's why you need a good
editor man cuz you had a few writers
fuckin throw stuff out there and you do
serious damage to your website or
magazine like you can really fuck your
shit up you could develop a reputation
you end up a bad reputation like a
reputation for being ridiculous Oswald
is attacking you is it for fun people
are looking forward to it and it rings
true yeah that's the problem is it rings
true what he's saying
yeah if you read those titles they're
all I mean those are great mock
salon.com titles they're great you know
but look if you go to select I get an
email from them every day and there's
some great things like the thing with
Jon Stewart mocking CNN for its
continued coverage they've got that
they've got an interesting thing on
Chris Christie like the governor's at
all you know not all bad at all but a
friend of mine hate advice for a while
he's unfuck that magazine because
because one article that he was offended
by that came out five years ago but I
mean yeah you can't blame the whole
organization because one thing fucked up
right
[Music]
[Applause]